at the beginning of the show we do this
thing where we're like put your like
raise your hand if you're an
entrepreneur most of the hands will go
up okay keep your hand up if you've
launched your business all right like 15
of the hands go down okay keep your
hands up if you have more than a hundred
thousand dollars in Revenue
okay hands go down a million dollars in
Revenue
10 million in Revenue 30 million in
Revenue we just keep going up to see
kind of like who is who who wins the no
small boy stuff competition of that of
the crowd because we're like there's the
people who are there they already kind
of know our story and they know our bits
we don't know them and so that might be
actually more interesting there was a
guy who was one of the people who's got
like he was at the kind of like 30 40 50
million level he's like um
yeah I uh I sell gear to fire
departments around the country and he's
like you know like we're like like hoses
he's like like hoses and uniforms and
you know nozzles and and like you know
just stuff for the fire department and
did he say that he did 57 million in
revenue of that is that what he said I
don't remember the exact number it was
something like that
[Music]
all right we're live what's going on I'm
back home
the live pod is over the show
the show is over
let's talk about your time in Austin the
light pod we should talk about a little
bit we might be airing that that episode
we got to go back and listen to it to
make sure that there's nothing that we
have to bleep out but what did you think
about Austin it seemed like you had a
great time had a great time dude I know
more people in Austin than in San
Francisco somehow so I think uh I don't
know if that's about Austin or that's
about me I think it's more about me not
leaving the house here in San Francisco
but when I left my house I went to
Austin I saw tons of old friends you and
a bunch of the crew
um had a great time stayed uh started
off in a haunted hotel and then moved to
a better hotel and then uh yeah it was a
good time you uh came in on something
like a Wednesday you left on a Sunday or
Thursday and Sunday or something like
that Tuesday five days Tuesday Tuesday
it's a Sunday you had you you spoke at
two conferences you were on the Chris
Williamson show which was uh that guy's
interesting yeah but what what was cool
having you here was I felt I felt
um
I missed our times in San Francisco the
2012-2018 era where it was like it felt
like all of us were doing the same stuff
then when you came in town we had
everyone we we had like three or four
dinners of like eight friends and it
felt like oh wow this is it feels like
it's happening again and actually it
feels like it's not happening to the
extent of what we experienced then but
there are a lot of really special people
here and it felt really cool like to to
appreciate that yeah you're right uh I
think people should do whatever we did
in our kind of like 20s which was moved
to the city where there's a bunch of
other people that are
um chasing the same dream as you I think
that's like a that's an amazing like you
could pick a city based on weather based
on location you could pick it based on
cost those are some factors but if
you're in your 20s and you're the type
of person who listens to this podcast
you're sort of entrepreneurial you're
ambitious I think the move is moved to a
city where boom to a place I don't even
know it was a city move to a place this
could just be a house in the town you're
in where you will be around other people
who are chasing the same dream as you it
is massively underrated like you will
not only get smarter faster but also uh
you bond with people and it's like those
bonds don't go away uh you will always
kind of remember when you were all at
the very upstart phase of what you were
doing
and we did this live pod and this live
podcast and the con so is me Sean and
Andrew the content was fine enough
whatever but we'll talk about that later
or we'll just air the episode but what
was cool was I met people I think we had
550 or 600 people it sold out and I met
and so we stayed out Sean and I and
Andrew stayed afterwards and like did
like a meet and greet with everyone and
you always talk to these people and I'm
amazed that these people would fly in
from all over the place I met a guy from
Malaysia uh I met people from all over
Mexico America North America uh who came
and they were like I came here because
in my town I'm a weirdo and it feels
nice to be around non-windows and I was
like what do you mean and I looked at
Twitter afterwards and I saw pictures of
like
so like basically we didn't let people
into the venue until right before it
started and in the line I don't know if
you saw this there was people
interviewing each other like for their
own content channels there's like people
are like oh I met this person who's
doing this I met this person who did
this I met this lady did you meet this
Mexican lady who moved to from like
Mexico City to Ann Arbor and she flew
down from Michigan it was her and her 12
year old daughter did you meet those
people I did I love that they were she
was like hey love the Pod this is my
daughter she listens as well we listened
together and I was like oh amazing you
know what do you I asked the daughter I
was like what do you what do you like
about the show uh because she was she
was quite shy in the moment and she was
like ah just yeah I like that it's fun
uh it just gets me laughing and then uh
you know I just learned different things
and it makes me want to go do like it
makes me want to go do stuff and I was
like you know that's the that is the
actual sales pitch right you'll laugh uh
you'll learn something and it'll it'll
get you excited to go do stuff
um and the mom was like you know thank
you uh for the Pod because it's the only
like it's the only podcast we can listen
to together that we can vote that we
both enjoy so it's like become a thing
we do and um you know that's probably
not that common but uh that was one of
my like Golden Nugget kind of moment
takeaways from the whole thing
yeah she was my favorite person I met
but anyway my point is is that it was
cool that like
um and what you're saying is what we saw
a very micro version of that with 500
people was like go to the place where
there's other weirdos like you and like
cool stuff happens and and that's always
really fun I met a lady who was like uh
yeah you talked about me in the Pod and
I recently sold that thing for 30
million dollars and she was like waiting
in line for like 30 minutes to talk to
me and I was like
yeah let's do some of the interesting
people that we met so there was a guy um
at the beginning of the show we do this
thing where we're like put your like
raise your hand if you're an
entrepreneur most of the hands go go up
okay keep your hand up if you've
launched your business all right like 15
of the hands go down okay keep your
hands up if you have more than a hundred
thousand dollars in Revenue okay so
hands go down a million dollars in
Revenue 10 million in Revenue 30 million
in Revenue we just keep going up to see
kind of like who is who who wins the no
small boy stuff competition of that of
the crowd because we're like there's the
people who are there they already kind
of know our story and they know our bits
we don't know them and so that might be
actually more interesting there was a
guy who was one of the people who's got
like he was at the kind of like 30 40 50
million level he's like um
yeah I I sell gear to fire departments
around the country and he's like you
know like we're like like hoses he's
like like hoses and uniforms and you
know nozzles and like you know just
stuff for the fire department and did he
say that he did 57 million in revenue of
that is that what he said I don't
remember the exact number it was
something like that was it was either 30
or 50 million something somewhere there
he said he had an exclusive right to
sell in nine states so like you know
beautiful business right because he's
got a basically a monopoly on selling in
these in these certain States he's like
won the contract or whatever and really
profitable business that uh you know who
even thinks that like who even thinks
about who's the who's the B2B e-commerce
for fire departments and it just gets
you thinking wow how many Niche
businesses are there because you just
kept meeting one after another uh do you
have any others that stood out I got a
couple more uh we went to dinner so we
had a dinner the night before one
business that I really like that uh I'm
eager to see if it's gonna work out and
not is called boom and bucket and what
boom and bucket does is I I don't know
if it's rental or if it's for selling
it's selling but I think is it selling
so basically if you are if you own a uh
or if you need to buy a um tractor or
like a one like anything caterpillar so
like dump trucks I guess uh boom and
bucket whatever you know whatever has a
bucket and Carries there's a market
plate yeah it's a really good name it's
a boom and bucket and it's a really cool
website and so they I think uh the
founder his name is Adam Lawrence he
previously was the CEO of Bolt bolt was
like this like high flying startup
one-click checkout startup to be
determined if it's gonna work out but
they raised something like hundreds of
millions of dollars at multiple billions
valuation
he left there after being there for a
while then he went and started boom and
bucket and he's telling me all about it
I think it's only a year old or two
years old still new so they're still
figuring out if it's gonna like take off
or not I think but really cool business
that I actually think will work once
they can kind of get uh uh uh to to you
know marketplaces you need supply and
demand it's really cool I'm on their
site right now so boom and bucket which
also
sounds like an amazing name for a bar in
Austin like you know a bar with like you
know dollar jello shots and like uh you
know the ax throwing in the back I feel
like that's actually in Austin people
just have that in their backyard the ax
throwing thing that's like that's what
it seemed like so no bro we all have
coal plunges and saunas
so the first thing on here is a two a
2012 caterpillar 420f
for somebody out there they're like oh
my favorite model uh I've been dreaming
about that one yeah 77 000 ships
Nationwide you click it and it's
basically like here's the thing it was
priorly used in construction for
concrete uh you know here's the specs uh
we inspected it here's what we found
that was great about it here's what
needs work it's got a residual oil
buildup on the engine valve cover no
active leak scene so they're adding
value by doing inspections and doing
close up detailed photos of the
equipment and then they say great you
can buy through us we will finance it to
you and we will take care of the
shipping to get this to you
um this seems like a great idea I don't
know anything about this Niche so you
know take that with a grain of salt but
um love the name love the idea and I
love that this guy went from like the
most Silicon Valley VC thing you can do
like a network effects VC funded
multi-billion you know unicorn that's
either gonna become 100 billion dollars
or go to zero and he's like I'm gonna
move to Austin grow a mustache and start
selling tractors online dude he had a he
had a thick beautiful mustache and he
was wearing cowboy boots and he looked
exactly he looks like you want him to
look he looked like he was in Disguise
yeah
I feel like you're just trying to blend
in in Austin so this guy's awesome his
name's Adam Lawrence I love Adam I've
I've gotten a gnome over the past year
so he was cool who else was was
interested um another one that I thought
was cool these guys were in the meet and
greet line they come up and they're like
hey love the Pod blah blah blah no
questions just want to picture
um or actually they have one question
they were like you know
we do franchise marketing and I was like
franchise marketer what uh say more and
they're like basically
five percent of McDonald's stores use us
as their digital marketing agency and
social media marketing agency
and I was like ah five percent of
McDonald's franchises that's like that
seems really significant they're like
yeah it's going great and this is
actually the second time I heard about
it and this is kind of my rule of two
which is if I hear about the same thing
from two completely separate people it's
like well roll up the sleeves
time to go down a rabbit hole plug the
nose you heard someone talk about the
same business or the same like literally
or the same style same style of business
so our buddy cieva had told me about
this these businesses so there's a two
businesses called one's called scorpion
marketing and the other is called
ferocious marketing uh okay I see it
normally seems like a little bit of an
overcompensation but they actually sound
like badass businesses yeah I need like
a I need like a like a like a rabies LLC
you know what I mean
it's like
yeah
fever
marketing or something
I need something like that I love that
hey we're from Dengue
um yeah
we're happy to help we make it hot if
you know what I mean
Genghis Khan Incorporated I love it kill
the competition
he had told me that one of those two I
don't remember if it was Scorpion or
ferocious does over 100 million dollars
as just a kind of like Google
pay-per-click Plus
um you know basically Google Ad Agency
plus maybe uh maybe Facebook ads as well
for franchises like they go to Every you
know Goodyear tires in America and
they're like yo you need to have a good
presence online this is what we do we
help could your tires franchisees make
more money in your location you pay us
whatever 10 grand a month and we take
care of your website your marketing will
make sure you're visible on Yelp and on
Google when people are searching for
tires blah blah blah and that's what
they do and they go do the same thing
they did in tires and then they'll do it
in Jamba Juice and then they'll do it in
you know one franchise after another
and so I kind of love this model I think
that this like this idea of general like
generic agency but agency that is
tailored towards franchisees I think is
great why
franchisees all are going to have the
same problem set you're going to have a
cookie cutter customer I love that you
typically if something is a franchise
it's got scale already so you know that
Niche is sort of validated third it's
the easiest marketing pitch in the world
once you get started which is that yeah
we do uh over you know if five percent
of McDonald's franchisees use us or
we're the largest Agency for McDonald's
franchisees we are the number one we
serve over 150 store uh franchisees
guess what the 151st is way easier to
sell to once you got to the 150 right
it's like it becomes a snowball in terms
of your marketing
um your operations can get streamlined
because they all again cookie cutter
customer they all need the same thing
and then lastly that type of customer a
franchisee they've basically put like
their net worth on the line to own these
franchises they typically are not like
these brick and mortar franchisees
they're doing that because they're not
super tech savvy or online Savvy and so
I think it's the perfect kind of
customer and you can just provide clear
Roi from month one and I think you could
do this in a lot of niches like I think
you could do this in like senior living
like my father-in-law has a senior
living facility
and um he is like he basically like the
entire business is just how's our
occupancy and uh you know if occupancy's
at 55 versus 65 versus 75 versus 85
that's like this that's a swing of like
10 million dollars just in that that
question right there oh wow um and so
I'm like great
hey Dad what are we doing for well how
are we feeling that occupancy right like
you know what are we doing and he's like
well
I don't really know how to do online
marketing because most people who own
senior living facilities are not the
most tech savvy he's like so we need
like uh like a come die with us Mark
he's like we host a coffee and donuts
like brunch for the local Hospital
nurses because that's like their number
one source of deal flow right now and
then there's these search engines like
like place for mom.com or something like
that and you know you you try you tell
them hey I'll pay you for leads but they
just don't bring you that many leads and
so somebody who can basically solve the
search query for like you know Senior
Living Austin or Memory Care Austin or
whatever the person who can rank you at
the top for that search is gonna be the
difference between 55 occupancy and 75
occupancy I think and so I think if you
found a niche or a franchise like that
doing the the sort of digital marketing
for it I think becomes very appealing
yeah you just have to run it which can
be challenging running those companies
are is very hard but getting customers I
think is is actually easier than but
what's the one thing to running a
company easier if you had good a good
way to get new customers it is like for
sure the number one like you know Advil
for all aches and pains when it comes to
running a business is well at least
we're getting a bunch of customers like
you know easily we have a reliable way
to do that uh every other complaint from
there is like you know just a little
little bump and Bruise another
interesting person who you met for the
first time was Nick Gray so Nick Gray
was like the we asked me to like MC our
event and then he ended up just
attending every other like dinner that
we had and he like emptied it hardcore
and what's interesting about Nick Gray
is you guys should look him up is he's
in like real time you can watch him like
become an authority on this very strange
topic of like hosting small Gatherings
right and he might be able to turn this
into something substantial and just to
give you an example of what happened we
had this like fancy restaurant booked
for this one dinner it got rained out
because it was like the table was
partially Outdoors so we went to this
kind of crappy bar and then we moved to
another bar next door that was also
somewhat Outdoors but had a roof and
Andrew one of our guests was like oh man
is it going to be cold and Nick was like
yeah it might be cold hold on and he ran
to a shopping mall across the street and
bought like a hundred dollar long sleeve
t-shirt and goes I got you and how
impressive is that he was The Ultimate
Party host which is no surprise because
that's what he does so his I don't know
him you know him very well I I just met
him and I'm and just I'm just got my
first dose of Nick Ray and I can't wait
for my second dose so basically
it sounds like he ran a company called
Museum hack which was basically
a kind of like a night adventure company
so you would go to a museum the tour
would be hosted by a local stand-up
comedian or magician or somebody who's
got some
Showmanship and uh and basically he
paired Showmanship with something that
needed Showmanship Museum tours and it
was a good company I think it was making
a couple million maybe one two million
dollars a year of profit he sells the
business takes the proceeds invests it
into I think did you say all of it into
Tesla or like just a lot of it
so previously he had made money because
he him and his family started an
aviation Parts business so they made
like the screens that go in like private
jets like uh like the uh navigation
screens with the earnings that he had
from that business he invested it all in
Tesla and there's these funny pictures
of him during the New York Marathon
years ago and he would hold up signs
that says buy Tesla because he was like
trying to show up everywhere and just
Tesla bomb
yeah yeah and then he uh killed it on
that and then he started this uh Museum
company with this proceeds he put it
into cloudflare which has not done well
but you'll see him all the time it's
really funny you'll see him like someone
will be like what's the best service for
this and he'll just reply on Twitter I
hear a cloud cloudflare is really good
you should check out cloudflare like
he's like promoting it and with his book
he says the same thing he's got this
book called two hour cocktail party if
you go on Google photos and look at the
reviews of any bar in Austin he's been
there and he's reviewed it and when he
reviews it he takes a picture of his
book in front of the sign or the food of
that restaurant as like Gorilla
Marketing that's all he does he does
little things you told me about this guy
as this kind of like super social guy
that's in Austin that's like now doing
this thing called a two-hour cocktail
party and um and he sold like out of 10
000 plus units of of that book and he
was like um and I couldn't tell at first
I was like well
is he an idiot or a genius and I think
this is a common game I play where I
meet somebody and I I'm playing the
Indiana genius game and the case for
idiot was like
wait so he like sold his company and
that was all in on this chest perfecting
this like owning this little sub brand
this Con this content brand around
hosting a two-hour cocktail party I I
can't tell you the last cocktail party I
hosted so so I was like he spent three
years and he was all in and then all the
things you told me about the way he was
promoting the book and books in general
are not a great business model so I was
like what is this guy getting at and
that was my like is he an idiot
but very quickly I've shifted into no
this guy's a tedious and here's why so
first of all it's a real problem hosting
a hosting a party a hosting hosting any
kind of party forget like a specifically
like two hour cocktail party but hosting
a dinner party is
something that is valuable if you do it
kind of stressful when you do it and
there's a difference between bad good
and great that comes into a bunch of
details and the details are things like
when you invite people how do you prep
them for it what is the email you sent
beforehand that reminds people even that
this is happening what it's going to be
about and how they should show up uh and
that when they show up like how do
people have to introduce themselves oh
he's a bigger yeah Gotta Have name tags
name tags help because whether you name
tag name tag name yeah you gotta have
name tags okay what else do you have to
have he's like well you kind of want the
event to Flow versus just having it be
like well whatever happens if we break
out into to random clicks of people that
already know each other or a giant group
where it's kind of awkward uh you know
what's gonna happen and so he's like has
his little sister he's like I'm gonna
have some other structured time and some
structured conversations and then back
to unstructured after the structured
because the structure gave us all
something to talk about in the
unstructured time he's got to say it
goes into little things like hey you
know if you host something at your house
like people nobody knows what the trash
is and so they're opening all your
cupboards of your house trying to find
[__] now they're just going through all
your [__] and then they just leave it on
the counter and now your house again now
the party's looking like a college rap
party just put a label where the trash
is let's just do that and he's got all
the little reminders and tips and tricks
for a hosts Okay so
solves a real problem that's kind of
stressful and kind of valuable if you do
it right like we've both been to parties
where the magic happens the conversation
just gets really interesting you meet
three or four people that you're like
become really good friends with you did
this actually like this is how we met
was it you host our dinner party at my
office and so like you know the right
dinner party can lead to some really
great things and the wrong one is just
forgettable okay
so now why do I think it's actually a
genius
I think he's got a win-win scenario and
what I mean by a win-win scenario is
that
whether this becomes a big deal or not
he wins the first part is
by doing this He is building like the
ultimate friend group network like I
think uh Andrew called him Andrew
Wilkinson called him a friend
billionaire he goes Nick's a friend
billionaire and he'll and Nick won't
brag about it but I'd be like what'd you
do this weekend he's like oh I was at a
friend's house I was like who he was
like oh uh Matt mollenwag the guy who
started uh WordPress yeah we were just I
was just at his house all weekend and I
was like what how do you know Matt he's
like oh I met him at a dinner or this
and he like has so many stories like
that and when you are a front
billionaire what does that mean that
means you you know a lot of cool people
so you're constantly inspired by the
people you're around you got a lot of
people who you know got your back into
love you and you have a bunch of of like
real connections and like real a real
social life which I think is like
I think it's kind of like one of these
like silent
like you know epidemics that's going on
right now is that most people I know
have like a really weak and feeble
friend group maybe I'm just in that
world I don't know but like a lot of
people have this feeling of like great I
work from home
I live at home I eat at home I order
food on doordash and like I don't see
another human being for like you know I
can go seven days without seeing another
another like person with a pulse or even
if you are seeing people it's all
transitional transactionals great I live
in SF or LA and I go to Barry's boot
camp and everybody rushes in and does
the thing and then rushes out and like
this like what happened like where am I
supposed to make new friends uh you know
that's not really like that easy for
most people so anyways I think that what
Nick has is actually quite rare so
whether all this is is he makes a bunch
of friends has a bunch of fun
experiences
um and you know he was showing me this
video on his phone he's like check this
out he's like last night after we hung
out I was on my way back and my friend
texted me and said you gotta check this
out it's flooding in my area but it's
created like this almost like fake
surfing thing like it was like flooding
on some Street and the water was running
really fast but there was like a lip in
the in the road and so he could you
could go on a boogie board and basically
feel like you're surfing and they just
did that for like hours and he had these
fun videos and I was like
cool I was just like on my phone
scrolling whether you were doing that
right like this guy's not only I was
watching billionaire he's gonna have
he's like an experienced billionaire so
I think that's the that's the bottom of
the win of if nothing else he gets that
but at the top I'm like
dude I kind of think this should be a
local franchise like I think that he
should basically turn this into like the
modern day Toastmasters like I think if
he wanted to this could be an enormous
business and it could help a lot of
people because he could basically say
look
open up a local chapter like
Toastmasters and
um it's just dedicated to hosting
awesome get-togethers of awesome people
I'll train you how to host them right
you fly out to me you attend one of
these that's part of your training and
um and then go wherever you live and
start hosting these things and uh you
know pay your membership dues to to be a
part of this and let's let's create an
international wave of people who want to
get better at hosting things and having
an awesome social life I think he could
create the next Toastmasters what do you
think
so Toastmasters uh so for those who
don't know Toastmasters I don't know
entirely how they describe themselves
but I I knew it as like a public
speaking Club so you spend 50 or 100 a
year something like that and you get to
go to a local chapter where you like
everyone practices public speaking but I
think they weave in some type of
leadership component where you can like
learn how to lead but it's all related
to public speaking there are non-profits
so you can look them up so Toastmasters
has 63 million dollars in assets of
which
looks like about 35 million of that is
just cash and then they did last year
something like 18 million 19 million in
membership dues oh sorry 25 million in
membership dues and about 30 million in
Aggregate and total revenue so like not
a nice that's very nice uh so it
definitely worked yeah exactly and I
think that like you know there's a lot
more people who want to be able to host
the party and build an awesome kind of
like social life for themselves then
there are people who want to get are at
public speaking and uh so I think this
actually has a lot more legs and it
reminds me of the game so I haven't read
his book but uh but the way Neil Strauss
wrote the game and was like hey do you
want to get better
you know like meeting women if so you
know this is a book that's going to tell
you a bunch of awesome you know sort of
War Stories plus techniques that that
can help you do that and I think that
this reminds me a little bit of the game
it's got the benefits of the game
without the sleaze factor of of the game
and so for that reason
I'm in and I just gave up I just gave
him I just gave him the thought leader
triangle with my hands for those who are
listening you start with the Pyramid of
hands going upwards and then on the on
the inflection point of the sentence you
gotta flip it down
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated whoa I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
did you meet anyone else that was
interesting or have any other uh
thoughts about uh people you met or
experiences I got a couple high level
thoughts a couple high level thoughts
the most so we do the meet and greet for
like I don't know it was almost like two
hours or something after the show
uh just like people are you tired after
that
um
I have this thing where relief gives me
a lot of energy so I was so relieved
that the show was over that I felt like
people had a good time
um and that I didn't like my trip was
over I was gonna go home and get to just
like be in my bed and not have to be I
was traveling with my two little kids
which is you know it has its own
challenges I had no less than 10 people
reference the size of the cotton candy
that your children had they were like my
wife wanted to see the show so she
brought my kids were two and three years
old to the show that's like you know
that's like you know opening up a a
lighter inside of a natural gas Factory
like you you kind of knowing this thing
could combust at any second and she just
had a backpack of bribes which I think
actually should be its own product from
traveling moms it's just a pre-made
backpack full of like little dollar
store toys that you can give out every
15 minutes to be like all right be
occupied don't scream and cry and think
about anything and just unbelievable
amounts of crazy candy that they never
get to eat like a bathtub size container
of cotton you've got a seven layer
lollipop it looked like you know those
like dude someone told me they're like
we saw Sean's eating Sean's kids eating
a kebab or like a hot dog or something
except Sour Patch Kids it was like uh
you know when the shake builds like a 95
story like apartment for himself in uh
in Dubai it was the the Shake Dubai
tower of lollipops it was incredible
yeah I had a bunch of people uh tell me
about that but anyway what were you
saying so I would say in the meet and
greet line the most common I would say
the most common questions and I don't
know what you experienced because you
had your own line and I had my own mind
so maybe yours was different
I got a lot of people being like hey
whatever love the show can take a selfie
and then got one question for you and
the question I was like oh this is gonna
be a
it's probably gonna be a doozy right
that they're they won't you know they're
getting they're using their one shot on
this question and it would the most
common questions the most obvious
answers it would be like
you know I'm trying to decide between
this or this you know what do you think
I should do
but what do you want to do
I really want to do this all right well
then you should probably do that one or
like I don't know it's like a few like I
mean do you want do you like do like one
more than the other like do you you know
do you want one if you if you did know
what you wanted what would you say
yeah I know you don't know what you want
but if you did know what would you say
and they're like B I'm like
cool do be then right or it'd be like
yeah and I and I hate giving that answer
because it's like uh you know not that
we're someone's hero but don't meet your
Heroes because like yeah we just give
you the most obvious right obvious
answer or the second one is like I'm
doing this this and this and I go oh
cool what are the results they'll tell
me I'm like what were the results last
year okay well just yeah keep going
sounds like it exactly either it's
working
don't don't mess it up or sounds like
it's not working
do you wanna like you're asking me for
investment and uh actually you should be
asking for advice right because it's not
working uh you know the same thing was
like I'm doing these I got these two
ideas I got one company I do this and
another company I do this and I'm really
it's really hard because blah blah
cool sounds like it into two companies
uh like do you think do you think the
optimal strategy is going to be to do
two startups at once or one like they're
like uh yeah one probably cool so which
is the better business like which one do
you want to do which one is working
better
and then they're like well no but see
this one kind of feeds into this one
and I'm like no it actually eats away at
all of your time in mind share it
doesn't feed into anything and they're
like hmm I'm like you know like Elon
Musk can run two companies at once he
might even be able to run three
but um
until you have you know like until your
palm is like you know a physics textbook
like you know until you can unless
you're built the way he's built like
it's probably not the optimal strategy
for you like if you're in this meet and
greet line I'm just gonna tell you right
now probably you don't want to be a CEO
of three startups at once and so
the obvious answer for most of them is
like but what if you just focused on the
one that's that you like more or is
working better like I think that would
probably work better than trying to make
both of these these fledgling things
work and so I felt almost silly that
that was the case
and what we're saying here about
everyone was searching because we met
like a bunch of successful people for
example probably one of the more
successful people we met was this guy
named AJ Patel who is like 32 or 35 or
something like that and he started a dog
supplement company which whenever I hear
about that I'm like that's the greatest
thing ever because who knows if like the
product works but he originally sold a
portion of the company at like 200
million dollar valuation and then a few
years later sold it for 650 million
dollars in valuation and he seemed
pretty like zen-like like he kind of had
his act together but still there was
some things where he was like trying to
figure out what to do next and like he
had normal questions that everyone else
had and on here you had everyone
searching yeah actually I want to say
one last thing about that previous thing
about most common most of the common
questions at the simplest answer that's
not a knock on those people what I meant
is
dude this game is not as complicated as
we make it I have the same I do make
those same mistakes and all it takes is
just a third party with like a fresh set
of eyes just like well sounds like he's
just picked the one you want to do right
or like instead of doing three things
try focusing on the one and it'll
probably work better or like you know
whatever and so I think that it's useful
to almost have that be your own coach in
that way and save yourself a lot of
Heartache because
that it wasn't a knock on those
individuals it's that is the common
problem
um is that we we don't have complex
problems we have SIMPLE problems and a
simple problem doesn't need a complex
answer it needs a simple answer so that
was my point there all right this to the
second thing yeah everyone is searching
it didn't matter who we were hanging out
with net worth zero net worth 100K net
worth 1 million 10 million 100 million
and the billionaire we had dinner with
everybody was searching searching for
meaning searching for what's next
searching for what they should be doing
with them their time searching for a
better challenge searching for a way to
to solve their problem
it just felt like everyone's searching
specifically a lot of people were
searching for like Direction and it
really made me like
it really highlights me the value of
when you know you when you have a clear
Direction the value of that to like be
grateful for that and find people who
are good at figuring that out because I
think if you stay in that searching
state for too long that shit's dangerous
it's like an Inception it's like we can
only be in the dream for an hour before
we forget that it's a dream uh you know
we got to do that thing where we [__]
cold plunge ourselves to get back out of
it wake back up it's like there is it's
okay to be in a Wandering mode or a
searching mode or kind of a thinking
mode like what do I want to do
but after six months after 12 months
after 18 months like
that [__] becomes you get lost in the
sauce and uh I felt like there were kind
of a lot of people that were lost lost
in the sauce uh that their their search
was sort of like almost indefinite and I
think that's that's dangerous
that's interesting and that's actually
really scary that's that kind of a
because it's one of those things where
if it goes on for too long it gets even
worse and then you know you're like
you know ass deep in it and you're like
oh no yeah you forget how to even start
the engine it's like this car hasn't
been on for a long time does the engine
start and I think you're good at this I
think the way I think you're really good
at this the way you are very structured
helps you because I think you're very
like regimented you're like for the next
three months I'm gonna only talk to
people and figure out what I want and
after three months I'm gonna have a
conversation with myself and shift into
the next gear and because you're that is
my read of it at least I I don't know
what goes on in your head but my read of
it is no that's exactly how time box
things and you know there's an argument
to be had for like just wandering around
and letting you know don't you can't
control everything
but I think having these creative
constraints these like time box
constraints helps keep you honest like
am I really am I even learning from my
wandering at this point or am I just
have I forgotten like my head for my
feet do I even remember what the hell
I'm supposed to be doing right now and
so I think you know you had a period
post hustle and pre-ampton that was like
your searching period
but it was like I think you knew you
were gonna search you knew you were
going to wander and explore which meant
don't jump into something really fast
but also don't let that last forever is
that right
yeah well I'm obsessed with time so like
even when I was 20 years old I had this
document I think if you Google like my
name and then CEO doc you'll be able to
find this spreadsheet and I would map
out I think I had thousands of them of
all these biographies of people I read
and I would type in uh like when they
started their apprenticeship when they
got successful and the time it took to
do that I was obsessed with time and the
reason time's important is I think that
the constraint is incredibly necessary I
read this book by Robert Greene and he
talked about urgency and that was the
first time that I learned about the
importance of urgency and so that's why
I'm obsessed with time and so usually
what I do is I have this thing called
worry time which is very similar to like
searching time but worry time is like
here's the period that I can worry about
this these following things so like it
could be like
you know I'm not sure that here I'll
make a list of all the things uh going
on in my life that are that are
happening right now that I'm not sure
about like it could be like this podcast
it could be um my relationship it could
be anything and it's like all right on
Sunday from three to eight I'm gonna
worry about right and I'm not and then
I'll like set time aside to worry about
it and then I'll send it and like lead
into every moment of every day and be
this underlying worry or anxiety that
just sort of like plagues you
yeah so it's just like uh you know like
have you ever used headspace the
meditation app there's this like cool
thing go ahead yeah I like com2 but Andy
the guy who would narrate it be like all
right today we're gonna uh we're gonna
do the meditation whatever now the cloud
is above you let's put all of our
thoughts and feelings and worries in
that cloud above us now let's just walk
a few feet away now we're away from the
cloud we can acknowledge that like our
worries are up in that cloud but we're
no longer under it and we can go back
under it when we're ready and worry
about it and so that's kind of where I
came up with like worry time and so I
have worry time and I also do the same
with like searching time so it's like
all right I'm gonna search for this
and then in three months I'm gonna say
did I find it or not no okay fine we'll
give another three months and then once
I find it it goes searching is done we
are no longer searching so I actually uh
turned off like this is just a very
small example I turned off the Twitter
DMS of my Twitter handle because I would
get all these interesting opportunities
but I said nope we are done with
opportunities I have the opportunity we
are going to pursue that and then at a
later date we'll open back up to pursue
New Opportunities maybe but right now
there's no nothing new right and uh I
like we my wife and I were joking but
it's not really joking it's like my rule
right now is No New Friends I don't need
new friends I have the friends that I
want that is perfect I'm not gonna go
out and hang out with new people No New
Friends because uh you know like the
searching time is done for now and we'll
open it up at a later date auditions
will come at a later date for new ideas
and new friends dude that's great uh I
love the way you said that I do a
similar thing but without uh I I hate
the word time I'm the opposite of you I
I want to get off the concept of time
altogether
um but my but in reality the result is
actually very very similar what I do
which is I focus on the word constraint
so how can I use a constraint to my
advantage I love this because naturally
I'm always constrained right like I
don't always have every resource at my
disposal to do what I want to do right
let's say I'm traveling and I don't
maybe have the time or the equipment to
get to the gym to do the same workout
that I was doing before
then how do I get excited about the
constraint okay I got this wall I have
the floor I've got my suitcase ah
interesting I can air squat the suitcase
and then I can you know do these like I
could do a push-up challenge where I'm
going to do 100 push-ups in the next
five minutes and I'm gonna see you know
if I how far under that time I can get
and you know you do that and you've used
a constraint to your advantage to have a
better experience so I always have this
thing which is I'm not going hour to
hour I think that's a really I think
time creates a lot of stress in people's
lives so I want to use constraints
without the stress of time so what I say
is like all right I'm trying to have an
experience right now what kind of
experience do I want I want a sweaty
workout experience okay how can I now
use an exp use a constraint to ratchet
that up and make it even better
um right like and that's how I want to
do things so I'll do the same thing
where I'll constrain myself all right
I'm gonna turn off DMS or I'm going to
do no do a No New Friends season and
I'll use these words like season just to
sort of time box them but without the
sort of urgency or stress of like the
thing you did where you're like how
successful were these guys by 30 dude
that would have just made me feel
miserable so I had to like tweak that a
little bit for myself where I didn't
want to always feel perpetually behind
in life
um and so my way of doing that was
focus on all right I'm about to walk
into this room what kind of experience
do I want to have
and get good at choosing that and then
be like how can I use a constraint to
like level that up to enhance that
rather than feeling constrained by
lacking some resources that I otherwise
would want to make this happen
I think the time thing is important
because you do compare yourself to
others and comparing yourself to others
everyone says is bad I actually think in
some ways it's really great because you
see what's possible just like if you're
like an athlete or you're like I want to
be like this athlete I want to be strong
but I want to be stronger than them or
faster or whatever but whenever we do
these events and I meet all these
amazing people like an AJ like a Thule
like an Andrew Wilkinson and I hang out
with them and I think I'm behind I'm
waiting that's the and that's dangerous
that's dangerous that's the thing I
referenced the other day when I said
there's the there's the um the science
of success and there's the art of
fulfillment what the comparing yourself
will help you in the science of success
it will motivate you it will put a chip
on your shoulder it'll get light a fire
under your ass but it's not going to
help on the art of fulfillment side and
so what some people try to do in life is
be like let me solve the success thing
first and then I'll do the happy thing
after that and I think what you'll do if
you look at remember my back to my
everyone is searching thing what ends up
happening is people solve the success
thing to try to throw a bunch of money
at the happy thing
it works to an extent but not all the
way there
the kind of disillusioned and they just
sort of fall back on well let me just go
do more success [__] at least back then
when I was only focused on success I
felt better and I know how to do that
but more than I know how to be happy and
uh and so or or it's like I thought this
number would give me the answer it turns
out I was just one question five times
yeah yeah it's actually it's not it's
not 50. it's actually 150. somebody said
I was just wrong they said it's always
three times more than what you got uh
like people always think three times
more then then I'll I'll chill out after
that I'll really move on to that next
phase and I think while I don't think
that's a bad path I don't think you end
up in a bad spot I do think there's
probably a better version of it which is
like can I do happy and successful at
the same time is that possible we were
talking and I'm gonna add them here but
it's nothing crazy but we were had
dinner with Andrew Andrew you know his
company as of Friday I don't know what
to say it was worth 850 million in
Canadian and I was like we were talking
about like what's next and or like we
were talking about like just personal
like motivating factors and he was like
like oh I was motivated because I wanted
to feel secure financially because for
some reason I always felt insecure as a
kid and you know everything comes from
like issues you had as a child and I was
like
do you feel secure now and he was like
you know what not really and I'm like
wow you don't we we're still not going
to feel secure at that number uh like
you you always need more and I always
and I couldn't decide if I felt negative
about that feeling or positive but I
have realized that that might be the
learning is that like you don't feel
secure a lot of people don't feel secure
regardless of what they have or what
they don't have like it's the it's the
same feeling of it's not enough like it
can get taken away
I I view it a little differently it's
more like the security doesn't come from
the money that feeling you want isn't
going to be is it gonna change when the
money changes in that in that way right
like uh I feel secure now and I have one
one billionth of whatever he's got right
like it's like you know he
why because I just view I just view it
differently I have different
insecurities that he's got right like uh
but on the on the financial one I'm like
as long as I still got my wits about
being my two hands I'm always gonna be
fine if I got my brains I got my hands
I'll always be fine so what do I care I
could lose all my money in crypto I can
lose all my money in this this business
could tank podcast I could say the wrong
joke could get canceled on the podcast
tomorrow
still got my hands in my my brain all
right I'll be I'll be I'll be all right
and so if it's like Fitness right like
if I put you in any fitness test
I think you would feel pretty secure
right like yeah I don't think I could be
like Sam we're gonna do a work like I
think if you invited me over you're like
let's do a hard workout
you know I'm not eating that morning I'm
about my I don't know I gotta be light
on my feet I gotta I gotta do like hey
was creatine working one day let me take
some of that like you know I'd be
stressing out because I don't have the
fitness security whereas I think if I
invited you over for a hard workout
you'd be like we'll see right or even if
somebody even if David Goggins invited
you for a hard workout maybe at that
stage you would feel feel a little bit
of the the lack of security but I think
for most people in most situations you
would feel pretty secure and so I I
think it's everybody's chasing a feeling
they think the feeling comes from a
thing the feeling doesn't come from the
thing the feeling comes from you and
comes from practicing having that
feeling and I think until people rock
that they're just not going to have the
type of feelings they want of happiness
and all this other [__]
speaking of which we have a very sturdy
audience I was putting my hand around on
people's backs take a picture
but yeah we had a whole bunch of broad
bunch of deadlifters what's going on
there was a there was a bunch of sturdy
ass people maybe it's a a Texas thing
but there's a bunch of big old boys that
we're talking and women like every like
there were so many strong people I I
probably said it at least 20 times uh
like you know it's like you're awkward
the meet and greets are weird I don't
know what to say to people uh so it's
usually like oh I like your shirt or you
look huge you're yoked but I said that
so many times yeah yeah we got we have a
interesting interesting demographic
there's like the people that look like
you the people that look like me and
then there's the people that look like
neither of us but it's kind of amazing
how well distributed it's like a bunch
of Indian dudes a bunch of really strong
white guys and then like and then and
then the other group which is a blend of
normal people
we had so many Indians and so many
Indians with the really thick accents so
I guess they just moved here do you
think that we are are we popular in
India because of the topic or because of
you
well
I mean there's a lot of a lot of
business topics out there they don't all
have that I think you know like anything
where's chamath from what's he he's uh
is he Indonesia he's from Sri Lanka
Sri Lanka I mean I don't know do they
they probably love him too but it was
like the six million people underwater
or something like that it's like a very
like I don't know how many of them even
have access to like you know know about
know about him but but yeah if he goes
down here it's like the uh cult
phenomenon him Naval biology like they
really really look up to to those people
no like it's like if you go to in China
the most popular person was Kobe Bryant
it's like Kobe Bryant was the star of
stars because of some combination of
like
he's got the thing that they want like
crazy like athleticism plus they piped
those Laker games into China and like
only Laker games for like a period of
time and so he was just in everyone in
China wishes they're a black man yeah
exactly and he was just like look like a
god compared to them right and it's like
I think you you like people who are
they're like you and so you feel like
you could be them and then there's
people who are so unlike you that you're
like you are so different I just I I am
in awe of what you are
it's like the uh Bjork effect so Bjork
you know is from Iceland which only has
like five million people and like
bjork's music sucks but every once in a
while she would be like number one on
the charts is because like everyone in
Iceland right cheer for her because she
was like doing something interesting in
America or like Bruno Mars if you go to
YouTube and look up Bruno Mars's videos
on YouTube they have like three and four
and five billion views on YouTube
because everyone in the Philippines
because he's like Filipino is like
that's our guy you know what I mean so I
guess that's why we have a really nice
indian contingencies because you're
their guy whereas with me it's just a
bunch of like uh you know like guys from
Ohio but whatever dude can I tell you
speaking of Ohio can I um
do a little bit here on Jerry Springer
what about him R.I.P died two days ago I
think
um yeah his story is kind of crazy do
you know much about Jerry's backstory
wasn't he the mayor of of someone in
somewhere in Ohio Dayton Ohio or
something but he was really the mayor of
was he was the mayor first and then yes
so basically his career is like he at 25
he's the advisor to Robert Kennedy
during his presidential campaign who I
think died or gotten assassinated or
something
um yeah then he's like okay goes on to
do like kind of like local city politics
ends up becoming the mayor of Cincinnati
for a brief period of time gets fired
because he solicited a prostitute I
think and got busted for it and so he's
like oh sorry like yeah it shouldn't
have paid for an escort or something
um so now he's like out of the political
game
and he's you know in his 30s I guess and
he's like what do I want to do next and
so he
he gets casted on to local TV to do a
political show it's like oh you could be
like our political kind of like talk
show type of guy
so he does that for for a little bit and
then he gets his own show so he's I I
don't remember what year this is like I
don't know 91 or something like that and
he gets his own political he's doing his
own political talk show three years go
by kind of uh unspectacular
and then the moment happens a new
producer comes in is like Hey look
this political show
it's going nowhere let's switch it up
and the Jerry Springer Show is born so
the producer comes in he's like look
we're going to shift it towards
controversy
um dirty laundry and basically like
we'll Captivate we'll make captivating
TV by putting Scandal on air and we'll
have like was it fake though so
uh there's there's different opinions on
this I read a bunch of like Reddit posts
to people who are producers on the show
or went on the show here's here's where
I think it met it out which is they
would cast for Scandal
people would say yeah that happened to
me the producers would intentionally not
fact check anything
and um so you could it could have either
been real for you or you could have just
been like if I do this I get to get on
TV I get a flight to New York I get to
go basically me and my my whatever
person get to go on vacation to New York
all sorts of pain we get to be on TV and
you know that'll be that and so for some
I think it was like truly real for a lot
they were like kind of like make it up
or they would embellish so it'd be like
yeah I cheated but like actually they
weren't best friends and I didn't like
we knew each other first and blah blah
and he actually knew about it already
he's not finding out on air but like
whatever we'll kind of recreate that and
was it daily or weekly so I think it was
a daily show it at its peak wow it's
higher rated than Oprah so he becomes
the number one Daily Show and for the
first time in people's so so here's some
of the kind of amazing things it goes 18
years on TV Jerry knows it's stupid but
he's like
this is what people want and I'm gonna
give them what they want and I had a few
takeaways from this whole thing right so
first of all Jerry Jerry just that's
iconic it's just so iconic and I love it
yeah that was it was it was the
pre-World star yeah
dude we're World Star World Star lives
in the shadows of Jerry so here's a
couple things that stood out to me
number one
he gave people what they wanted not what
they what he thought they should want
and in fact he started with what he
thought they should want oh here's the
latest on the local political issues and
where we stand and blah blah and he
pivoted and he pivoted the right way and
I think as entrepreneurs
um there's a great like Gary Halper
quote but he says no more never has more
money been lost than trying to Market to
somebody what they should do versus what
they want to do and as a marketer you
got to internalize that now there are
some people that are not in my cult that
that hate that phrase they think that's
terrible that the world is terrible
because of that they say no
shouldn't we strive to be better
shouldn't we strive to help the world be
a better place and and not that like
these sugar-filled cereals and these
like you know dopamine social networks
and all this stuff
and so some people hate that that's true
and they're fighting against it
as an entrepreneur I'm in the camp of
you are here to serve customers you're
here to give them what they want if you
want to win you give them what they want
you get if you want to win really big
you give them what they want in a way
that no one's out no one else is giving
it to them or maybe even that they
didn't even realize that they wanted
people didn't know they wanted this and
you're the first to provide it but
that's the game of business and uh to me
so so anyways I think he's a great
example of giving people what they want
uh two he pioneered a new format so his
whole format of like putting this dirty
laundry on air and the fights the
bouncers the like the the the pregnancy
test for the DNA test reveals like this
guy's a goddamn innovator uh number
three he became number one he'd be
bigger than Oprah in his prime and
lastly what I love was he uh dude he did
5 000 episodes he got his friends to win
too so his security guy Steve who became
like a character a character on the show
like their best friend Steve says you
know the most wonderful things about
Jerry and Steve gets his own spin-off
show later after the after the Jerry
Springer Show so I love that he kind of
brought friends along the way and then
they when he eats they all eat and there
there was a few few good examples of
that and the other funny thing about
this and people people liked working for
Jerry people I could tell you yeah like
it was like the opposite of Ellen uh
like Ellen is seen as this like you know
America's sweetheart and then behind the
scenes was like you know a menace and
apparently Jerry was the opposite it's
like he was seen as a menace to society
and actually he was kind of a sweetheart
um from what people said now maybe it
was just the guy dies and no one wants
to trash him but like that's what I
found
the last thing though that I thought was
interesting was that in a weird way
because this show is really popular like
in the early 90s
his show was actually the first show to
expose people to like to people being
gay or trans or like all kinds of stuff
that's like totally lgbtq like and he
was like this is a for a lot of people
in America they had never met or heard
of anybody who was in any of those
categories and so he kind of was like
the Band-Aid rip-off moment for for a
lot of America on these things which I
think is also kind of amazing the real
world was kind of like that too I went
to uh I went to an all boys high school
and and like I remember being like 14 or
15 and for some reason the high school
it was like a good the culture of the
school like young men felt fine coming
out and saying they were gay and I
remember like meeting these kids and it
was like the first time I've ever done
that and like someone who admitted to
being gay and at first I was like uh you
know back then you you would make fun of
people and then I
you realize oh that that's that's
horrible you obviously we shouldn't do
that and it's they're my buddies
um and then it goes back to and
therefore because I love you I'm gonna
make fun of you just like I make fun of
all my other friends yeah yeah and
because I love you I'm not going to
treat you differently we're all boys and
we're just gonna tease each other over
someone has braces someone uh you know
likes men whatever it doesn't matter
we're gonna make fun of ourselves and
that's just a way that's the way that
young boys show that we accept each
other that's how we show love it was
just a mini it was a mini Jerry you know
Jerry was first you know like like well
we're not not gonna make fun of this
person because of this and that we're
actually going to do it because it shows
that we're gonna it's normal we're gonna
normalize it so who knew Jerry was so
Progressive you know what I mean the guy
was uh Robbie we got Rosa Parks Martin
Luther King we got Jerry Springer he's
just one of many in a lineage of
pioneers breaking down social yeah I saw
he died dude he seemed he always seemed
really likable I remember watching him
like did you watch it like did when your
grandma like babysat you or something
like that's like what I remember doing I
was just home after school by myself
yeah like at like it was like four
o'clock when you get home from school
you watch Jerry and Oprah I remember
watching all or when you stay home from
school being sorry you watch Maury yeah
staying home for a sec watch price is
right and [__] yeah I loved Mari Mari
was the best too he's gonna die soon too
I just looked him up while we were
talking he's 85 I think uh so the
Legends the Legends it's a it's a
passing generation saltlier type of type
of people who's doing this now is there
like a thing now like where does this
happen does this happen on Tick Tock or
like twitch or YouTube or something I I
don't see that's a good question of
content even though it's a good one you
know another great one like this my
sister still listens to this every day
when she drives her kids to school
cheaters on radio this the show where
they really bust cheaters like like
that's still a thing it's a big it's a
it's a big thing in the uh FM morning
radio space which is a very small thing
in the world now I think that is
actually it was Joey Greco you remember
Joey Greco the host is it just one I
feel like every city just borrowed this
format
Joey Greco was like the more famous host
and at one point he got stabbed you
don't remember that episode where he
gets stabbed dude he like gets stabbed
and like the thing about the thing about
that era of like the 2000s and 90s the
reason it was cool was
we don't know if it's fake because there
is no one right tweeting you know what I
mean you like think it's fake but like
no one has a platform to like expose
like that they went on the show and so
that's kind of why it's hard to like
recreate some of these things it's like
we didn't know like I I wasn't sure
wrestling was fake or not until like you
know five years ago I I who knew you
know what I mean held out huh yeah tooth
fairy and uh Vince McMahon maybe maybe
there's a way yeah no one no one knew
but no that's a good question I'm
looking it up now cheaters the TV show
Joey Greco did the TV show version and
then the later host was Peter guns right
the radio version is basically they call
the wife calls in it's like I think my
husband might be cheating so then they
call the husband as a woman
I don't know how I don't know actually
how they pull this off I gotta ask my
sister what the actual format is because
I don't know how dude
easily because like I mean you'd have to
get a cold call from somebody and be
like yeah I'm down uh so I'm not sure
exactly what they do or maybe they
called oh I think what it is is they're
like he might be cheating with my friend
Rebecca and they fake call as Rebecca
to try to like to catch him in the act
and then they just do they hit the
button and three-way call merging the
wife and she just goes off on him on air
it's it's incredible content I mean like
anybody who's that who's a content
creator out there like if you're not
studying cheaters you're not even trying
if there's a subreddit called public
freak out you ever go to public freak
out I see that I've seen a public recap
on uh that's my favorite subreddit
that's my favorite that's my version
that's my version of Jerry Springer
public freak out and popping where they
just pop like zits and [__] I love that
big fan of that one and public freak out
I was on the front page of uh popping
one time I had a picture get 60 000
views so it's just whatever can I
endorse you for that on LinkedIn how do
I dude I swear
I had to get like a cyst removed from my
like head and I right before I went
under surgery I was like hey Dr Brian
can you do me a favor here's my cell
phone number can you take some pics uh
while we're in surgery and send them to
me I want to post them on this subreddit
and he did and I got 60 000 views
I have a I have a folder right here on
my Safari or my Chrome still it's called
brain and it's like I took like before
before during and after photos I was at
number one I'm popping so no big deal I
think it's literally no big deal
actually that's the cool part about it
I guess that's the episode we did a
recap and we talked about Jerry Springer
all right that's the episode
[Music]
foreign